hello there DC fans
I'm Greg I'm John Monday morning and we
got a 20 or 30 second tease here for
birds of prey and because we ignore the
Ghostbusters one not every comments
gonna be about this one so might as well
check it out but I feel like we might
even get a look at the cast at least
something like this might actually be
well worth it in the end before we do
that I wanted to say thank you to
everyone who has been downloading and
following us over at the Stardust app
people over there we do 30-second
reactions for any film TV show or
trailer a lot of times to do little
micro sketches post daily it's so much
fun people have fun we should have fun
with us too
[Music]
whoa I'm gonna have to slow this down
this season that is meant to be slowed
down this is our time oh here we go here
we go let's see we could recognize I'm
not gonna pretend to be like birds of
prey expert by any means but there are
some characters in here that I am
excited for that I'm familiar with from
other properties or some appearances
that I've seen in other DC comics before
when you really really slow this down
the only ones I really recognize it that
I'm aware of that are casting because I
haven't really befallen the news here
you do get a good look at Mary Elizabeth
Winstead as Huntress
who is one of the OG birds of prey
that's very excited I think even think
Huntress is actually on the birds of
prey with WB show when that was out
which was a really good show and you got
Rosie Perez inheres gonna be a detective
her name on Toya which I heard about
which I think it's fun because she's
actually a really funny woman wonder if
she's gonna looks like such a serious
role here of course Margot Robbie as
Harley Quinn even MacGregor is actually
I know this is like a female director
you know birds of prey female like group
but the one I'm personally most excited
for because because I'm a man who's some
testosterone is Eva McGregor is black
mask black mask is one of the biggest
Batman villains and this is all in the
bat world essentially actually has a
black mask you know you McGregor here
you gotta show the sexy Ewan McGregor
face yeah and I think at this one point
with the Gotham cast on I think that is
Cassandra Cain who is one of the back
girls who's not Barbara Gordon I think
forever ago what I heard was that the
birds of prey are assembling and they
got to go rescue Cassandra King I was
very curious to try to get a good look
at a black canary in this one because
Black Canary is a character that it
appears heavily and the arrows show a
couple of different versions of her in
the arrow show as well I know that's not
exactly a hundred percent comics
get in there I always liked it wasn't
like there's a TV version that I'm very
much familiar with and now we can also
get the live-action version so I was
really hoping to get a cool look at her
I imagined that with the canary cry the
power that she has that works really
well in the show how much cool that
would actually be in a movie with a big
freakin budget like that yeah well I
like the you know they're hinting at
they got her on a mic here and stuff
like that you know which is a nice
parallel with the singing and stuff and
then you got a Chris Messina here as
Victor Zsasz who I didn't become
familiar with until I was watching the
Gotham show who's it's like super lethal
assassin that I was like so fascinated
by the character and I'm like was he a
comics character that was like looking
him up and he is I don't imagine this
film will be r-rated but one thing about
the Gotham show that really surprised me
is how violent that show can get and
Victor Zsasz is a ruthless killer and he
is someone who I'm very much excited to
see brought into the big screen another
character who was on a TV show but now
is being brought into the DC extended
universe villains yeah well I'm excited
to see Chris Messina get to sink into a
role more like this you know where he's
probably gonna get to play more of a
character I mean a the first time we
watch this teaser I didn't even
recognize his face with that blond hair
in the and the like silver teeth or
whatever and I'm yeah like I like what
that guy does so I'm excited to see him
get to play a more like eccentric wild
kind of Gotham City character you know
what this looks like to me is a giant
test screening footage it's an
announcement that we started filming
yeah we had everybody on set and we got
them in a soundstage and we're like
let's make something that gets people
excited yeah in terms of it's not a real
trailer by any stretch it's test footage
of what these actors look like in
character but in a weird way I think
that's actually more exciting I like
this more than whatever that
Ghostbusters T's was because you're
actually getting a look if these actors
and what they're essentially going for
within the roles and the fact that the
cast is actually all officially here it
gets you excited knowing oh they're
actually really making this DC tends to
have a billion films announced ahead of
time and you don't know which ones are
actually gonna get made and then looking
at this and the return of Margot Robbie
is Harley Quinn I think there's playing
excited about and they
have a think Cathy Janna surname is
directing this movie I haven't seen her
other films but you know this is the
that time so I'm excited for that yeah
well and I mean I don't know if they get
to make these but I feel like these you
know announcement teasers are actually
kind of cool because you get like a
brief taste of what the movie might be
like I mean I don't know if this is
completely the visual aesthetic they're
going for but I imagine there will be
some of this neon some of the year
Nevada yeah and there's like close up
you know backlit shots and stuff like
that I don't know it's a teaser with a
lot of style and it seems like they're
at least trying to get some of that
across you know what the movie might to
be like you know I imagine you want this
to have the attitude your movies gonna
have and I feel like it does have a
pretty fun and yeah and the intriguing
attitude and I mean props to Margot
Robbie because this is like her baby
yeah actually introducing this one
producing this I heard that this plot
that they have is actually taking it
from what gavin o'connor was gonna do
it's Suicide Squad - which I find kind
of funny how she sort of borrowed this
and brought it over here hey if you're
one of the things in the DC EU that has
momentum will show up in here it'll be
great yeah I think it's funny because
the Joker footage is released online of
walking Phoenix now they're doing this
it's like their new version marketing
yeah and I think with comic book
characters being brought to the big
screen and a new version I feel like
that's actually works I feel like if it
was a sequel it would have worked but if
they're brand new characters or a new
reimagining of them with a different
actors in my excluding Margot Robbie
yeah I feel like there is something to
actually get a little bit excited about
well yeah right now is the Wild West for
DC in a weird way because you have these
strange hits and misses and you know
that that they love to course-correct or
at least they're very on top of doing
that so yeah I feel like you can't take
something familiar from Suicide Squad
like Harley Quinn but but make a lot of
necessary changes and things like that I
feel like they're in a place where they
are using parts of their continuity but
they're also not beholden to their
continuity anymore so it could this can
be pretty exciting if I have one
complaint about everything I've heard so
far is why is the titles so freaky
long I did not know this till I was oh
yeah pulling it up just now birds of
prey and the fantabulous emancipation of
one harley quinn is that a concrete
title cuz to me that kind of sounds like
a desperation thing to try to make you
go no one's gonna really know these
other people or but they might know who
harley quinn is so let's really Quinn's
name in the title and in a way that
doesn't just sound like birds of prey
led by Harley Quinn a yeah I mean it
sounds like the the physical formation
of the title feels like they gave it's
Harley Quinn and said what do you want
to call it yeah would you know in that
way I'm like okay props but in the other
sense I'm like I I very much wonder if
that is why simultaneously there is that
flipside to me where I'm like I really
like the commitment to how yeah like
that is such a weird extension of a
title or at yeah you got I kind of
appreciate it cuz it could have been
something that just sounds cliche or
whatever but that to me sounds like some
strange comic book so I actually really
like that at one part of me is kind of
cynical on the other partner he really
admires it yeah alright well hey before
we wrap this up we shot a we thought
there was a Shazam trailer coming out
last week so we did a patron in the day
shoutout for a man named Taylor Bentley
and we recorded it in advance because we
were like okay if we record this in
advance we can get that trailer off we
were thinking ahead away trailer to not
drop but we have that footage roll it
and before we wrap this video up let's
give a page in the day shout-out to a
handsome young man named Taylor Bentley
I don't know if you know this you know
how she is Sam isn't actually an acronym
for all the Greek gods well Taylor is oh
yeah John is a fact yes and and Taylor
is an acronym as well for many things T
stands for Tom Tom Cruise a for Apple
after Gweneth Paltrow his daughter why
for Yahweh cuz he's that lordy oh yeah
al for Lord cuz he's that Yahweh o for
Octavia Spencer he's a big fan and our
for Kevin Spacey cuz he's weird yeah
so Taylor happy to give you a shout-out
buddy all right guys you can subscribe
to the reject
nation click that notification bell and
you could check us out on the start us
app download is free to download free to
use and we post daily so do it now